if some part of your politics is genetic
then the most important decision you
make in your child's political ideology is
who you mate with, right? Because
your genes and their genes join together
to have children who have particular kinds
of political biases that are influenced
by your genetic propensities.
But how do you know even when
you ask people maybe they don't know
maybe they're lying to you. How do
you actually know in an automatic immediate
way with somebody else's ideology is?
And for certain reasons we speculated
that it had to do with smell. And specifically
pheromones. This shows you why we thought this.
So this is a slide where you
you can see the extent to which
certain chromosomes are associated.
And when it's above 3 x 10 to the eighth (power),
where you see it's significant,
those are likely to
occur not just by chance. Right? That it happens
in a systematic way. And the ones
that you'll see this is political ideology
by the way. We're looking at the genes that
are associated with political ideology.
This is one of them. And what you'll
see is that these are the things that are...
the chromosomes that are associated with this
are those that are related to smell.
That are related to olfaction and
pheromonal strain. So we have these intuitions
based on the genome-wide analyses that
maybe smell had something to do with the
way that people were able to
automatically determine unconsciously
(this is not a conscious process)
the political ideology of people that they
might get involved with. We did
a study where we looked at facial and body...
Both sound: we taped people's
voices saying "Hi how are you?"
We manipulated them so half of them were
just neutral "Hi how are you?" Half of them
were more seductive like "Hi how are you?"
We also took pictures of people. And
most importantly we did a paradigm based
on the "wet t-shirt test."
Although we didn't actually use t-shirts.
We had people have gauze pads under
their underarms for a day. And there's
a particular protocol. They have to
wash their hair. They have to wash their body.
They wear it for 24 hours.
They can exercise, but there are certain
foods they can't eat. That can't be around
candles and other things that smell.
Specifically you can't sleep
with another person or an animal that night.
You kind of can't believe people will
do this for 25 bucks, but they do!
And they come and...
they give you the pads the next day.
And then what you do is you freeze them
and you slice them up... and you do
various things. And then you bring in another
group of people, and you have them smell them.
And you ask those people, well, what
does this smell like to you? Is this a
trustworthy smell? Is this somebody that
you think is warm? Is it somebody you
think is competent? Is it somebody...
blah blah blah
So what's interesting is there's
absolutely no correlation on all
these things like is this person warm, are they
competent, are they trustworthy...
there's no correlation. We ask people
can you tell if this is a liberal or conservative?
Can't tell at all.
But you ask them Do you like to smell?
Are you attracted to this smell? Do you want to
sleep with this smell? And it
completely predicts whether or not that
person's ideology matches their own.
They can't tell you consciously. But the attraction
is there. So we had a 190 people.
We used various pictures. We have
these voice samples... by the way the
voice stuff was interesting. We didn't get
any findings by whether or not the voices
were seductive or neutral. But what
we did get are asymmetries by conservatives
and liberals. So liberals
really don't like the sound of conservative voices.
And conservatives really don't like
the smell of liberals.
And this is the slide that shows this.
This is conservatives smelling conservatives.
Liberals smelling liberals.
The M and F have to do with males
and female. And it's a
little backwards right so this one is
males smelling females, males smelling males,
females smelling... so the people who like
each other smell the least are...
Women like each other smells the least.
This was a heterosexual sample I should say.
So you can see that there's
there's differences. And there are
asymmetries. But these are
all statistically significant differences
where you can see that these are related
to people's automatic, you know,
unconscious inferences about how
these things work. This study was very
interesting when I did it. Because the
first day I was really not sure it
was going to work. And we opened up the
vial. And I gave it to my lab manager.
And she smelled it. And she's like, yeah, it's okay.
Because we were kind of like,
is this going to gross people out?
She brought in her boyfriend and said: smell this.
And he smelled it and he threw up.
Like I had to do this Vegas thing on him
to stop him from throwing up. And he's like
"That is rancid!" And I smelled it.
I'm like, it's not rancid. She smelled it and said
it's not rancid. And I was like
this study is so going to work.